so what is emergence it essentially
relates to Collective ensembles of
objects collectively self assembling to
form something very very different from
the individual constituents one of the
very exotic forms of emergence phenomena
with
superconductivity and this is quantum
emergence in action if you took a single
electron or a few electrons you would
not get superconductivity it would not
be predicted from the model the way
super conductivity was discovered is
that first people took materials um
cooled them down to very very low
temperatures discovered that they lost
all resistance to the flow of
electricity that there was this amazing
uh property of levitation so it was an
experimental Discovery and then they
work backward and said okay how can we
form a model that now explains
this